hey Gary yes um quick advice for the
Hispanic community the same [ __ ]
advice I gave everybody has hard work
patients bring value patience hard work
bring value patience hard work bring
value to somebody who had 90 percent
open rates and 68 percent click to cart
rates in 1997 that doesn't exist anymore
but you know what else doesn't exist
anymore getting [ __ ] 50% of your
Facebook page to see something with your
organic reach but he had hoped like or
like like so I think it's a very viable
option but I do think I do think that
email thank you
email is a mature platform which means
it's going through mature things which
is it will continue to subtly decline in
the macro but it's not dead people love
dead Prince not dead it's over priced
and my big thing with email is if it's
not my favorite thing to be what I only
like to be one-dimensional when that
thing is the hottest and best thing of
the moment I'd much rather be
one-dimensional social and and when I
say one-dimensional social I mean really
good at it and really good at social and
only social then I'd like to be really
good and only email and then eventually
when social is not the hottest thing
then I won't want to be that I'll want
to be you only one dimension total boys
for VR blockchain or under attack
got it that's the answer I make pretend
on my parents eyes I know it's a little
weird it's actually the truth I don't
know if it works for everybody but I
Irie calibrate my perspective if I'm
frustrated in the micro and say if this
was great and I bought the Jets and I'm
time man of the year and I invested in
the next Facebook but I got a phone call
that my parents were going to Miami and
the plane crash they died how would I
feel horrible worst ever [ __ ] everything
makes me not worry about losing the
clients it's because I don't think I'm
filming an agency I'm building a human
infrastructure to scale all my ambitions
and wants and needs in the next chapter
of this mission I have 150 million
dollar company in revenue and and highly
profitable and and it's not even the
business of building my plan is to wait
for the economy to collapse and by and
by under priced assets that were over
leveraged and then run them through the
IP that I've been creating
so I'm paying I'm doing on the economy
relaxing I am setting like what ten
years whether it's tomorrow or whether
it's 31 years from now I'll be ready so
I thought I thought that my superpower
after meeting super men and super women
was oh I'm better at this one thing than
everybody ah [ __ ] the way to really
scale it as humans
thank God I love humans that I'm good at
HR and the vulnerability you have in
that is actually mitigated by Who I am
let me build it my ability to push
awareness around a disease to sell a
sneaker to make you the governor of
Texas in a decade is gonna be
uncomfortably large and and I've met and
I'm almost like you know how like sue a
lot of superheroes comic books start
with the doctor by accident doing it on
themselves
that's literally what I'm doing I've
deployed my thesis on myself to create
brand awareness
aka theme it's actually working I
speaking of your what's that
not necessarily you know it's a the
intercept no I want to be right about my
thesis and it's the collateral of that
if I wanted to be famous I wouldn't have
been a wine merchant and wouldn't have
liked right like my behavior proves that
I didn't you know like I would have went
to Holly like like I was 34 years old
before I made a single piece of content
you know like you know what I mean no I
don't want to be famous like baked into
you though right
what's baked into me is I like people
but baked into me is I'm charismatic
what baked into me is I have gift for
gab you know I'm creative like I got it
but it's not my agenda the machine and
the strategy of creating I am far and I
mean far more fulfilled that I'm the
person that created me not that I made
because it proves my thesis is it's also
why I'm such a hardcore practitioner do
you know how good it feels to sit
amongst people that are doing and know
you're doing and you know what you're
talking about you know how hard it is
for fearless leaders and you know sales
or CEOs or whatever it is to actually
still be practitioners you know many
people get an inch of success and then
want to sell how to be successful I
don't sell that people sometimes allude
to me doing I don't do that there's
nothing for sale you're not giving me
money I'm actually the reverse I'm
giving the best [ __ ] away from great I
think boats but a personal brand will
always outpace the better a business so
money dude starts with one so because of
course I have a Facebook page a lot of
follow us so if I need to make another
one then it starts with zero again your
Facebook page is probably at zero as
well because even though your followers
not a lot of them are seeing the content
yeah they see the code they see Michael
F is other one looks at my personal name
so Instagram and Twitter and so on it's
only my facebook it's my company's
avocado but I changed it in my own name
yeah you know understand just no no
because I hire again and the person that
hire says okay I work for Fe cada which
is my company but at the moment I have
noticed a brand anymore because I'm
focusing on my name so I'm now
struggling what should i there's no
right answer there there I think if you
have the bandwidth and the capital you
build up both because you're building a
brand during underpriced attention I
don't think Facebook is underpriced
attention anymore yeah I think Facebook
is appropriate priced attention and if
you're the best at it and you can do
longtail Facebook it's incredible and
would you also do it on Instagram votes
because
personally I think so because there's
things your business can do that you
don't want to do yeah of course a
business can throw more right hooks yeah
a business you know
yeah a business when you when you want
by the way when you get burnt out for a
month maybe a business can continue so I
think close if you can of osmosis I'm
not crippled if they're off a little bit
you're not expected to be like you
basically I prefer it I think I'm right
about what I'm saying
I'm just not crippled by them being a
little bit off not a lot so I deposit
employees you can't really quick media I
want to be more on because their math
creative I don't want to over impose my
will
I'll let them lose as long as I feel
like we're a better deal for the
customer that's paying us than the
alternative then I can put my head on
the pillow but I'm okay if the company
is an 84 to my 100 because I think if
they spent two million dollars or
somebody else didn't get a 39 got it
[Music]
you you hunt and the way you hunt is you
you network like have you gone to your
phone and texted every single person
that's in your address book and ask them
do you have anybody that needs marketing
services my business is young
whether you met them once and put your
phone in or whether it's your best
friend from four years ago I'm sure you
haven't cuz nobody does that but that's
the ghetto [ __ ] you have to do when
you're at your point you hunt right you
need customers you have a phone book
with address both of you have it you
just you just like everybody me included
it feels uncomfortable sometimes to ask
it just not everybody on the phone and
really afford no no you know we didn't
hear what I said
I didn't say do you I said do you know
anybody this is where this is where I'm
very fascinated by the way I give advice
versus the way it's consumed words
matter notice how I said notice how you
this is very interesting
notice how the subtlety of you asking
everybody on your phone
do they know anybody who needs marketing
services means that you could hit up
everybody but when you thought I said to
you asking them it made you say no for a
lot of people I'm in the business of yes
and so everything I do gives me a chance
for yes by me changing the the little
subtle word that you might have not
heard because it was lad or your brain
heard of the different way of you
hitting up everybody on your phone and
asking do you know anybody who needs
marketing services my agency's young and
I need customers versus you hitting up
somebody and saying do you have money
now you didn't ask them for money you
ask them for a referral which means you
can ask everyone
[Music]
five making it about them not about you
you have 20 people sit down with alt one
when you get home let me give you
something very tangible when you get
home I want you to you guys are partners
you say yes I want you to to take every
single employee out for breakfast lunch
or dinner and love look when you get
back home I want you to sit down with
them individually I want you to have 20
meetings that are an hour and a half and
I want you to start the meeting with we
are building a big company for the long
term we need you to be here in five
years for that to happen if you actually
think all 20 are great even if you don't
you have a different conversation ready
this is our company I think this guy's
great I sit down and say bro I need you
we're building something real what do
you want are you motivated by challenges
money title don't be scared we don't
have it all to give to you right now but
I need to know you and by the way in
four years you may fall in love and get
married and start a family and then it
might change but right now the way
you're living what are you about what
are you about and then you go to the
next person and next person and by the
way you go to this person and you're not
as pumped about them and say hey Karen
I feel like so we're building a real
thing here and we want to have dinner we
want to talk to you a couple things
we'd love for you to be here as you
probably know like we know it's not
perfect right now we control this
company what are we not doing well that
isn't allowing you to be pumped or on
fire 100% accountability and 100% about
them is how you build a big thing long
term that's all I know I don't know
anything else it's actually it
absolutely works firing them after after
I take on responding I either but but
but so we called the intermedia the
honey Empire the honey Empire
so firing his empire you got to build
the business but honey's first honey
over vinegar so how do I deal with it in
the macro firing them in the micro
before I get to that taking on full
accountability for their non success
like I told them and seeing if I can fix
it and if they don't it takes two to
tango it's my company's like if they're
not willing to help me make it better
for them then I'm willing to move on we
fire very slow but very comfortably
because we've exhausted and we've gone
radical candor we've gone optimism and
honey then it's not working we go into
Dennis the reverse Claude our chief hard
officer tomorrow has a difficult
conversation
we've tried extreme honey on somebody
tomorrow's gonna be radical candor it's
not gonna work
we look for when you re kindness I think
so
I think skills are commoditized I really
do I do and I don't want to
underestimate craft but she can be tough
it is much easier to teach somebody a
skill than to rewire their childhood the
end consumers all of you my mentor and
my inspiration and my oxygen is the
collective everyone so I don't know a
lot of [ __ ] about things that people
think I know like I mean I tilman
Fertitta today on my podcast who has you
know multi-building owns the [ __ ]
Rockets owns like all these [ __ ]
restaurant brands I knew nothing I'm
interviewing like enemy you know right
now I know of him because you know I
know of because I live in the world but
I never go deep because it's not gonna
inspire me or tell me anything your
actions on why I'm always so good at
what I do
I see it first because I'm in it
[Music]